hello everyone and welcome to a video
that features a most interesting story a
story that went
viral some 10 years ago it's about a
tournament it was a it was a chess
tournament played in vandeveyer in 2008
and uh we will feature one game it's a
christian bauer
a french grand master against anna
rudolf
and this is the event where anna rudolph
won both her international masternodes
and
women grandmaster norms uh he started
she started the tournament with a win in
round one and now she faces the top seed
in the tournament it's like we said
uh french grandmaster christian bauer
and it is
after this game that this whole story
begins as it's quite interesting
we'll discuss it a bit later uh but
first let's check out the game but even
before game we do have a nice photo
challenge uh it's a nice photo by david
lara so best of luck to everyone
i will give you a couple of hints it's a
very good friend of
anna rudolf and also she is anish
geary's wife
so there you have it best of luck to
everyone now let's check out this game
already uh from the first move the grand
master uh chooses uh
not an everyday approach he goes for b4
uh the polish opening
uh we have e5 the standard reply and now
not going for bishop b2 immediately but
rather
a3 and okay we have d5 it's a
standard the most standard principle
there exists if your opponent allows you
to take control of the center
uh then by all means do take control of
the center
so okay bishop b2 knight to d7 e3
bishop to d6 simply developing c4 d
captures bishop captures on c4 knight g
to f6
knight to f3 and we have castles uh
queen to c2 by bauer
b6 uh ana prepares to develop the light
square bishop
uh e d3 bishop to b7 knight bd2
we have a6 uh
bower castles b5 bishop to b3
and now rook to c8 preparing to push c5
uh bauer count counters this he plays d4
keeps control of the c5 square
uh he captures on b4 e captures and now
bishop to d5
uh all all right we have bishop captures
knight captures and
now comes knight to e4 preparing to grab
that bishop on d6 but we have knight
seven to b6
and now even though uh grabbing this
bishop it might seem like a night idea
knight c5 is also a very nice move and
the c5 square is a very nice outpost for
the knight
so by capturing the bishop pawn captures
uh
queen to f5 as the queen is attacked by
the rook queen to f6 and black is
perfectly fine here queen captures
knight captures
and uh this bishop wouldn't have that
much fun with all of these pawns on dark
squares it would be very hard to
to activate it so after knight 7 to b6
rook 8 to d1 instead c6
we have knights to c5 and here comes
rook to a8
here anna decides to defend the a6 pawn
uh it's very important
to note this as this was one of the
games where
uh people started being suspicious about
her using external help
uh from some engines or super computers
that uh this move uh
engine never even mentions it this is uh
you know uh the top recommendation by
engine is actually
uh bishop captures on c5 uh either
bishop not bishop captures on c5 sorry
knight to c4
uh there are a lot of options here rook
to e8 also a nice engine recommendation
bishop captures on c5 is a nice engine
recommendation but the top engine
recommendation is actually knight to c4
a very nice improvement on black's
position
where white is not able to capture the
a6 pawn because now rook to a8
will come with a double attack against
the a3 pawn
after knight goes back knight captures
on a3 and this is now a very
beautiful and active position for black
on the other hand also
knight captures bishop captures is an
idea uh but
then after the captures white would have
a much better pawn structure here on the
queen side
knight here we can play knight d2 knight
captures queen captures
and we would have this very nice punch
in while white's
pawns wouldn't be that that great on the
queen side and the
white pawns are on the dark squares but
white got rid of his uh
weak dark square bishop here so it would
be an alright position to play for both
of them
but okay rook to a8 by anna defending
the a6 pawn we have rook f to e1 and
then now comes queen to c7
pressuring the h2 pawn so now you could
play something like h3
it's what i would play the grandmaster
decided to go for g3
with the same idea preventing this
pressure against the h2 pawn but also
keeping an eye on this f4 square not
allowing the knight to go there
uh we have h6 and then now comes knight
to h4
okay preparing to bring the knight over
to f5 we have
rook for d8 and now comes bishop to c1
uh
with future ideas of maybe sacrificing
on h6
uh bishop to f8 ana brings the bishop to
help out with the defense on the king
side
knight to f5 and now comes a5 as there
are
obviously no tricks on the king side
pawn captures rook captures and
now comes queen to e2 preparing to bring
the queen over to the king side to join
the attack
uh rogue goes back to a8 now comes queen
to g4
pinning the g7 pawn now knight captures
on h6 is definitely an idea ana moves
the king king to h8 and
now comes queen to h4 with some ideas
now there's a triple attack against the
h6 pawn so perhaps there are some ideas
here
but ana says no there are not uh
rook to e8 is played even though the
engine's uh suggestion is king to h7
uh the engine would prefer if the king
joined the defense of the h6 pawn
but okay here i'm most likely i have no
idea
but the grand master probably went into
a deep think as there are so many
options to
to play here uh you have to calculate
everything you have to decide whether
knight captures an h6 is even an idea if
night captures on g7 is an idea so we're
just gonna cover
uh some basic uh sacrifices here knight
captures
pawn captures bishop captures bishop
captures queen capture so does this work
for white
uh king g8 we have rook captures for
example rook captures and now queen to
g5
if the king goes to the h file then the
queen can of course keep checking him
and
this would be a draw by repetition uh if
the king starts running away
for example queen to h6 check and king
to e7 uh now white uh can bring another
piece into it the attack rook to e1
check king king d8 queen to g5 check
and uh now you have to block this knight
to e7
uh and then now comes rook to e6 most
likely the grand master found this move
as it doesn't allow black to
to capture it because knight captures
would win the queen and
also it doesn't give black all that many
options white has a very nice attack
very nice position black is up a night
but
those knights aren't very harmonious at
the moment uh for example king c8 now
getting the
king out of the way now comes queen to
h5 uh pinning this f7 pawn
if you capture then of course you will
lose the game and after rook to f8
the game continues but uh the engine
gives this as a dead
draw there is no way for either sides to
make progress but
uh i'm sure the grandmaster spent a lot
of time here
another thing aside from this knight
captures here you could also go knight
captures here but it
brings us to a pretty much same position
captures captures captures
and after king j8 we reach the same
position
also possible after this rook 28 move is
to simply first capture it and then
after captures
uh you can go into the same variation
yet again captures captures captures
captures and then we reach queen g5
check
where we can go into the same line so
although uh white uh
can get at least a draw here the grand
master decides it's not worth it
there's not enough you know uh uh
fuel to power this attack uh he goes
king to g2
improves the position of his king and
wait for ana's move
anna goes queen to d8 immediately offers
a trade of queens
uh we have rook capture 78 queen
captures 98 and now comes queen to g4
this was basically the last moment in
the game where the grand master could
have gone for this bishop captures an h6
idea and after
captures captures captures captures uh
into the
same queen to g5 line uh but here he
played queen to g4 and now it no longer
works here anna played knight to f6
attacking uh bauer's queen queen to f3
and then
knight b to d5 we have g4
uh white doesn't really have all that
much to push for
to push with so he has to play something
g5 uh
h4 g5 definitely an idea uh b capture
bishop captures on c5 d captures on c5
and now queen to e4
here anna says that uh her pawn
structure is better
uh white has a weak a3 pawn and he has a
funny bishop on c1 that
has to keep an eye on the spawn it will
be it will be a much better position for
black but
white doesn't have all that many options
h3 is played defending the pawn
uh king the g g8 anna prepares to
improve the position of the king and
now queen captures knight captures and
here comes uh
bishop to b2 uh this bishop to b2 as
bauer
will say state later in his interview
and this interview was posted like in
every blog and every famous newspapers
in the world even the new york times
published
this interview uh but we're going to
discuss that a bit later he
he puts bishop to b2 as uh the losing
idea uh in this not losing idea but this
will cost him a pawn and as
they are reaching uh time trouble now it
will be very hard to defend this
uh instead of this uh bishop to be to
move with knight to d4
uh he says the position is still
playable for white
but okay that's not really what we're
interested in bishop to b2 was played
and it's very interesting that
uh how anna will take advantage of this
the important thing is the bishop on b2
is undefended so let's see what happens
here
anna has an option here does she want to
guard the g7 pawn by pushing f6 or
perhaps
go into some immediate exchanges for
example knight captures on c5
bishop captures rook captures on a3
bishop captures on h6 and
now starts pushing her b pawn
this is possible and uh
might mighty might even work but she
goes for a different plan she pushes f6
first she defends and now she after
knight to d4 is played going after
uh the c6 pawn only now uh does she play
uh
knight captures on c5 uh there's no
point in
guarding the c6 pawn for example rook
here you simply capture and you've
eliminated
the defender of the knight on d5
captures captures and after knight
captures on c5 the material is equal
pretty much a dead
draw so after knight d4 knight captures
on c5 is played
knight captures on c6 and now uh feel
free to pause the video here
and find the only move that allows anna
to push for advantage in this position
and it has something to do with
the move we already discussed uh so
i will give it a couple of seconds if
you want to decide whether to do it or
not
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
endgame player
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show knight to f4 check
is the move uh the idea is after king
moves now comes
knight to d3 the square is defended by
the other knight and now you see the
problem
attacking the bishop that is undefended
on b2 which is basically the defender of
the pawn on a3
regardless of where you move the bishop
uh black is going to capture it and then
going to capture the a3 pawn
and here uh in time trouble grandmaster
christian bauer was probably not very
pleased with himself
he could have gone for rook to b1 which
would make things a lot harder
for anna for example knight captures
rook captures and brook captures on a3
uh this would come with check after king
moves uh at least he would already have
a king on e2 and already a rook on b2
uh not allowing this pawn to even uh
be pushed but here after knight after d3
bishop to d4 was played and okay rook
captures on a3 threatening all sorts of
discoveries
knight b2 for example winning the
winning the rook bishop to e3 now
opposing the rook and now comes the b4
uh rook to b1
now you have to put the rook in front of
the past pawn
uh b3 is coming the knight is guarding
the b3 square
uh we have knight to b4 and then now
comes b2
as the knight from d3 is already
guarding the b2 pawn
so if you look at this position and the
position we've discussed here
the pawn is uh on b5 the king already on
e2
rook here the pawn can't even be pushed
uh
we have this position where the pawn is
already on b2 and
the white rook is very very unhappy on
b1
so okay knight c2 attacking the rook
rook to c3 and then
knight to d4 here we have king to f7
also a very nice moment for us to
mention that
the engine gives 95 check as the
absolute best crushing move
uh as king g2 is followed by knight to
c4
attacking the bishop i don't really have
much to do here after you play 92 attack
the rook here comes
knight captures with check captures and
now rook to c2
pinning the knight king moves and now
comes knight the
knight to b3 and there is no defense
against knight to d2 either check
winning the rook or if you move the rook
or if you move the king
the knight will simply go there just as
well attack the rook you will either
have to sacrifice the rook or
or move the rook and then the pawn can
be promoted but okay anna has a
different plan it's time trouble after
all she wants her king
from g8 to come all the way to b3 so the
king
starts his journey king f7 we have king
e2
now comes knight to a4 we have king d1
uh rook to c4 now comes knight e2 and
now the king can come
closer into the game king d2 we have
knight to b4 regarding all of the
squares around the black pawn
king d1 and now king to d5 we have f3
and
now comes knight to a2 bishop to d2
we have rook to c7 preparing to bring
the king over into
uh the game but also getting the rook
away from the king you know it's
time trouble you never know you never
want your king and rook close to any
knights
so okay h4 we have king to c4 now comes
king to c2 but now knight b4 kicking the
king back as its
check king d1 king b3 the king is now
very close and now there is nothing to
do here anymore the king is threatening
to come to a2 whatever you play
knight d4 check king arms here you have
to give up the rook
or if you try something like bishop
captures the king will capture and still
there's nothing to do here the rook is
cutting off the king from the c file you
will simply
play king v3 approach the rook and it's
all over so here grandmaster played
knight to the c1 check but
it doesn't help we have rook captures
rook capture spawn captures with
czech king captures and now knight to c3
uh it's a full piece up so this is
completely winning but
the grand master decided to play a
couple of more moves bishop b3 was
played
knight cd5 bishop d2 we have king to c4
and
now g5 uh as it is two knights it's not
a knight in the bishop so
there is a remote possibility that
something like this could happen for
example bishop captures g
captures and after f4 for example if
black knight
wasn't there able to capture the pawn
then g5 and then if black actually
decided to exchange
all of the pawns then after
you get a position like this then it
doesn't matter that black is up two
pieces
you will not be able to win this game
even if you can stop the pawn
uh two knights uh and the king are
not able to deliver checkmate to a king
it's it's a temple idea but
uh it is possible in some lines where
white actually has an extra pawn but i
don't think
this is uh even this is even close to
to such a uh such a position
but okay uh you know perhaps that's why
he decided to play a couple of more
moves uh g5 was played h captures we
have fun characters and
now f5 simply putting a pawn on a light
square not allowing any further
exchanges we have king to d1
uh king to d3 and now bishop to c1
knight to c2 was played
bishop to b2 attacking the g7 pawn and
here
on move 65 as anna pushed to g6 placing
both of her pawns on light squares
uh finally grand french grand master
christian bauer decided to resign the
game
so yeah uh a very nice game and a
brilliant victory against uh a grand
master who was at the time over 400 elo
points higher rated
than anna rudolph so definitely a nice
scalp
to take home with you and uh it's
interesting that after this one uh anna
uh
achieved two more victories so after
four rounds she was four out of four
uh here i prepared uh some a photo this
is a photo of her in bauer playing from
this tournament it's not a very high
quality photo but still
if you know if we have a photo we should
definitely show it
and here we have a part of an interview
with anna
i will put all of the links in the
description below as always you will
you will be able to find an interview
with anna an interview with christian
bauer an interview with the organizers
uh
an article in new york times so if
you're interested in the story a bit
more do check it out
uh but just uh you know to
tell you a bit more uh here they say
another participant
in the vendor or vanderveer open uh
maribor charrenco hinted us that some
players were uncomfortable with your
strong games
she says yes there was a trio who just
simply couldn't believe i played
by myself and accused me of cheating the
three of my names
uh international master oleg krimonosov
grand master vladimir lazarev and
international master ilmar
uh star starostits uh they don't really
know how i cheat but
they are sure that i cheat crib also was
telling stories about nowadays
high technology and so i heard my lip
balm became
the most suspicious lip balm secret
technology that sounds ridiculous will
any small kid believes
believe such a thing yes ridiculous
indeed i usually went away from the
board when it wasn't my turn to move
uh i like to go out to the fresh air and
also to wash my face moreover i played
most of my games on the stage
broadcast it so i didn't have to sit at
the board to see my position and yes the
lip balm was always with me kids
uh be aware arika is in it
so uh after having after achieving four
wins in a row
she faced uh grand master lazarev and
after only 11 moves at the grandmaster
offered her a draw which he accepted so
as
christian bauer said for his interview
for the new york times which you are
very welcome to read in
in the description below uh he said that
he he actually believes that
the other players were convinced that
she was cheating because first
uh 400 lower rated opponent then
christopher bower beats christian bauer
uh in the second round and continues
winning uh then
the grand master lazarev was obviously
too scared to play against her
he thought she might be using an engine
so he offered an early draw on move
11. but then the worst thing happened in
the in the final round in the final
round
uh her opponent refused to shake her
hand before the
game even started and uh not even the
before the game even started
she had to leave all of her belongings
with the judge uh they
inspected her little box with the limb
lip balms and everything
so that's very nervous that will get you
and you had a perfect tournament so far
uh she also played a wonderful last game
but
in the end uh she lost to that game uh
and she also says that uh her opponent
played like an
anti-engine system where something like
b6
c6 d6 e6 or something like that uh but
yeah like i said you
you're more than welcome to read a lot
more in the description below
and another very important thing is uh
uh grand master christian bauer said
that he never at one point believed
that uh anna was cheating he just says
that uh
after this critical uh critical move
bishop to b2
that uh uh he didn't go immediately for
for knight d4 uh with an attack on the
c6 pawn he first decided to go bishop b2
to
improve his attack on the g7 pawn this
was his critical mistake and that he
says that
after this anna played a flawless game
and they really had to move fast because
it was time trouble and everything there
was no way for her to
cheat and that he didn't really think
that uh her other games against other
players uh
were also were you know played with
outside help with an engine or a
supercomputer
uh but that it's very hard for some
higher rated players that uh
you know uh to come to peace with uh
that they have just lost to a lower
rated players uh which uh
i'm sure you'll you you are all used to
if you're playing online you know
whenever you beat a stronger player
you are always a cheater and when
someone beats you they are always a
cheater of course
uh so i decided to include also a
description of
anna's profile on twitter uh they're
among other things as a chess
commentator tv reporter
uh freelance edutainer a detainer is
obviously a word it's like an
educational entertainer
not sure if it's really a word but in
today's time and age definitely should
be
passionate and loud yoga and zumba
aficionado and there you have it
lipstick maniac just international
master and olympic player so
uh probably she included this in the
description so that her future opponents
know that
when she is using her lip balm or
lipstick that
uh she is not consulting a super
computer that she's just
a maniac so that's pretty much it uh
there is a lot more to this story a lot
more photos to this story all of it will
be in the description below a lot of
links for you to check out
and you know impress your friends with
your vast knowledge about
this story uh so yeah i would like to
thank uh and johnson and agar mataro's
dog for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon
most likely with a game from the sink
field cup or perhaps even bobby fischer
story if i'm done
preparing it so yeah thank you all and
i'll see you soon